The Joe Rogan experience. It's a conversation that I think is a fascinating one,
the conversation of reparations.
Cause it can be no doubt that something horrible happened to the black community
and they're still suffering from it. But I'm especially in the deep South,
when you look at these places where the people who lived are the direct
descendants of slaves.
And then these are the same impoverished neighborhoods that no one's ever done
anything to try to fix, right? So how do you fix it?
Uh, you first have to start with a subconscious monitor, the black mind. Uh,
and the problem with the black mind is defect that the black mind starts off
with a defeatist mentality from the day you're born, you're taught, uh,
the white man is out to get you. So you start off with a boogeyman and then, um,
you're taught that you're a slave, right? Uh,
so when your subconscious mind believes that the beginnings of your race is a
slave, how do you aspire to be more than that?
So in order to correct a black community,
you have to teach black history or so-called black history, or what?
I would say African history and chronological order. Before we were slaves,
we were Kings. So how do you,
how do you have a whole entire nation of 40 some odd million black people and
majority of them never heard a queen and Gola who never heard of the Songhai
empire to Mali empire? You know, none of this stuff, right? King, Masa, Masa.
How do you, how do you,
how do you raise a people's level of awareness about this stuff?
When and how do you elevate them to want to do things in life when they think
they are asleep?
That's the first thing that you have to do to help black people.
You have to teach them who they are.
That expression, before they were slaves, they were Kings.
The problem with that as a King, as a Monarch,
and a Mark is one person who controls giant groups of people.
You can have a bunch of Kings.
There's not a lot of Kings can have a nation of Kings.
Correct. But that's very different from saying,
you know that we had four kinks, right? Let's say there were just four, right?
That's better than saying Harriet Tubman, Fred Douglas, and these free slaves.
Right. You actually have to see at least one King.
I see what you're saying. At least say so.
See one advanced human being that also looks like you,
that came from the same part of the world where your ancestors came from.
So recognize that the trajectory that you and your family are on as a direct
result of being enslaved at someone was enslaved in the past and brought over
here against their will. That's why there's the negative mindset.
That's why there's a negative self image is because there's this great history
of oppression.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, when you think you are a slave,
you can't operate outside of that.
And even if you don't think you're a slave, you think you're inferior. You know?
Do you know who ms Pat is? No. Hilarious comedian,
one of the funniest human beings alive and she was here and one of the things
she was talking about was when she was younger that when she would see why
people, she wouldn't look him in the eye. She would get nervous.
She felt inferior being around them. She just wanted to get away.
She didn't feel like she belonged. Right,
right. And a product of not knowing who you are,
not knowing your own personal power. You know,
when you look at the second Punic war as a Carthage,
you had a Hannibal went through the Alps, which is, you know,
mission impossible. And he went all the way to the, to the doors of a Rome.
And Rome said, yo, we ain't coming outside to fight you, bro. When he come back,
that's how strong or powerful the army was. They said, we don't want to fight.
They knew if they came outside those Gates, they would get their ass. Whoop.
So how do you,
how do you have a people that walk around not knowing that a Hannibal,
a Barco is a WellStar, uh,
studied war general today. The Pentagon still studies him,
right? So how do you, how are you operate in,
in America as a black person and not know who Annabelle Bargo knows?
Well, it's difficult, I think for people that were born in American,
all their known ancestors from America to even relate. Like I'm,
my family's mostly from Italy and Sicily and some of them from Ireland.
I don't relate at all. I visited Italy in the summer times.
I don't relate at all.
Right? So then the other,
the other CYOP is the effect that we would have natives.
We were not brought here on slave ships.
That's not economically sound. Does that make sense? Uh,
so when Christopher Columbus guy who wanted to, well,
Chris Willem has got to the Caribbean according to a primary source.
They basically said the first thing he did was take slaves.
He didn't bring slaves. He took slaves from the Island. He captured people.
So when you have colonization,
you gotta remember United States was only built 13 colonies at first, right?
You think this whole land was empty? No, there were natives here. Right?
But today we're taught that natives as some other people know,
natives are the melanated African being that has come here since the, the, the,
the beginning of the Mali empire would soak on about, uh, 14,
13th century. We had already come here from Africa. Really? Oh,
yeah. Yeah.
We had already come here to the United States or to this land mass.
This landmass we call the United States.
So the way to the ocean current works is it works, uh,
from Africa leaves out of, uh,
West Africa comes to South America and the Caribbean.
That's just how the currents go. You don't need no paddle boat and nothing.
It'll just occurrence. It's take you there and then you travel up.
But we had already been here.
All you gotta do is look up the story of Sarah erector.
Sarah Wright is a wealthy, so-called native American. Uh,
I think she was a Choctaw tribe or one of these tribes,
but she was wealthy and, uh, she wanted to VIP pass to go somewhere and,
um, they had her classified as a free person.
Why don't we know about the wealthy so-called black people in America?
Why don't we know that there were black slave owners in America?
Why is that not taught? Why is it not true? How many black slave owners, man,
this did the natives here had slaves.
They would trade in with the so called white man. Well,
they definitely did that. Natives and slave people of other tribes, right?
So if those,
if those people are us to so-called black man at those natives or us,
then we have to tell that history and say how we did have territories and we
did, you know, carry our commerce and we weren't slaves. We were slave owners.
But the majority of African Americans that lived here were brought over here.
No, no, no, no. That's not economically sound.
What do you mean by it's not economically sound like there were slave ships.
All right. Let's say you wanted to have a, you want to sell marijuana, right?
Right. Would you, uh, import marijuana?
Would you grow it here if it's already here? Well,
it depends on whether or not marijuana grew here. Well,
can you go marijuana here? You can, but we're just talking about marijuana.
Like, what is something that you can't grow here? So,
so what I'm saying is people were already here.
Does it make sense to go all the way to this other continent to bring people on
a boat when we know that half of your stock is going to die?
You wouldn't do that.
So how many people do you think were brought over from Africa on slave ships?
Cause that definitely happened. Uh, I don't believe it.
What do you mean you don't believe it? I don't believe that story.
You don't believe that Africans were brought over on slave ships, correct?
I believe it may have happened. You know,
maybe people were brought over as slaves,
but I don't think that the black people in America came from Africa on slave
ships. I believe the people that were here were slowly conquered.
First they got to East coast and then he started spreading out West,
little by little Cochran. And when you conquer a tribe, what do you do?
You went slave them. Their pow right. Okay. That's what you do.
So you, after you conquered his tribe, you, you, you make them slaves. Now,
how do you conquer the natives here?
So let's say you got this tribe is warn against this tribe. Well,
this tribe goes talk to the white man. Why? Man says, yo,
if you help me wipe out these people, then boom, you know,
I'll help you with whatever, whatever.
So they get together and they wipe out this other tribe,
not guess what the white man now outnumbers this Trop say he wipes them out.
You just kill two birds with one stone. You just keep moving like that.
But I'm still confused.
There's a great history of slave ships being brought over from Africa with
Africans that became slaves and worked in the South.
Do you think that's lies? History is his story, right?
What about my story is my story now Valley,
but if you do 23 and me on someone from these parts of the country,
you'll find out 20 days. That's is 23 and me. So when I,
when I, when I take a a 23 and me test, right? Yes.
What's it going to tell me about Africa? That's a good question.
We should find probably going to say, Oh,
you're from Kenya or you're from Angola, you're from this, right? Right.
These things, these borders were created by Europe
in terms, yes. Right.
In terms of like what parts of Africa and how it's distributed and what's a
country and what's not a country. Yeah. Find the Afrikaner's and Dutch.
Yeah. Okay. So you can't classify me based upon a European name.
I understand that. But they're saying geographically geographic location,
you can call it whatever name you want. Right?
They can tell you where your genetics originated.
I've got some weird shit in me. I've got like 1% Asian.
I don't know why it's there. 1.6% African.
Cause also the weird stuff that you find in your DNA that like your ancestors
and ancestors, ancestors, this was somewhere.
Let's walk down that path. Right? So either way,
if you take black people here in America,
do they DNA sample and it point back to Africa. What does that say?
Says black people in America are Africans.
Now the argument is where we brought here or where we already here.
Did we bring ourselves here or did the white man bring us here? You see,
when you say to white man brought us here,
what you're doing is you're removing our ability to transport ourselves.
You're saying, Oh, we didn't know anything about boats. That's a draw. Tommy.
You try and tell me that we didn't know that there was a landmass here.
The only the, the Holy white men knew there was land to the West.
But when you look at the Holy white man, he said, when we got here,
we met black people. Go look at the primary source is the guy.
We met black people. When you got to Caribbean, me, my black people.
You think the Caribbean is right next to America and a Warren in America.
That's interesting. Does it make any sense? Well,
you go to Suffolk sense that you do have people that have traveled,
whether it's Polynesians that traveled to Hawaii or people,
I mean there's the Omex, uh,
who has thousands and thousands of years ago in South America.
They have purely clearly African faces on this.
I mean really the noses, the lips,
I mean they look African and that was a South American culture that existed and
we don't know anything about them other than the fact that they have these
gigantic stone sculptures that have African faces. Like again, again,
just go to have, you can pull up the ocean currents.
I've seen that Graham Hancock is, I've heard about him.
You read his stuff. It's really fascinating because he's all about that.
He's all about the fact that the idea that human beings were probably living in
advanced civilizations far longer than 14,000 years ago.
They did travel all over the world and that you do find the remnants of these
ancient cultures that we have no explanation for throughout the Amazon,
you know, and throughout different parts of, of uh,
South America and central America.
I mean, when you go and you look at rail European history,
you had the Magyars would believe that if they took a bath that was bad,
right? They didn't even want to change their clothes. They,
they thought that dirty was purity.
When we talk about the more going into Spain and into Europe,
the stories in the history,
our history says that when we met the So-Cal Caucasian,
he was sleeping in the barn with the animals and we told them, no,
you can't sleep in a barn with the animals. We taught them etiquette.
We taught them running water. We brought that technology to Europe. Now,
if we brought the technology to Europe that saved Europe from the black plague,
you mean to tell me that if we save the white race,
that we weren't already in America already. When we brought the technology,
when Rome was dependent on Africa for food,
I remember when the black print black plague hit Rome. The cause was,
uh, one of the, uh,
officials was still in the grain that was coming from Africa.
So there was famine hit Rome.
If your source of sustenance is from Africa,
how will you superior? You're not,
you get your full from me. So if you get your full from me,
who's more likely to travel this globe? May. I'm the source of food.
And that's the first thing you need to survive on this planet.
So if your whole civilization is depending on me to plot, to plot,
to dependent on me, to supply fool, I made it to America first.
It's just that you won the war and you got to tell the story.
Is that their only source of food? I mean, it's a source of food that Rome hat,
right? But Rome is also very close to Africa. Well, let's talk about that.
What kinds of food did they have? Well, I don't know. Some very rudimentary.
It was a very rudimentary, uh, civilization that wasn't all, uh,
what is cracked up to be when you go look at what the Greek said about Egypt,
when you go into Egypt, it's like, yo, it's like [inaudible] city of that time.
The ultimate,
if you really want to talk about African civilization being advanced,
Egypt is the ultimate because Egypt to this day is still unexplained.
No one really understands how they built those things.
No one understands the how old the culture is.
That's another thing that Graham Hancock and dr Robert Schoch from Boston
university who's a geologist, he's pointing to water erosion and the temple,
the Sphinx,
that leads you to believe that that place might have been as old as 9,000 plus
BC. So it absolutely is, if not older to Pharaoh Ramsay.
There's also different styles of architecture, right?
There's an older styles of architecture they find deeper in the sand.
They think it might have been indicative of an earlier kingdom.
And then there's also the new Bian structures of some of the faces,
particularly the Sphinx, the Sphinx, they believe had a lion's face.
And then when they were conquered by the new beacons,
they changed the actual structure of the face of the Sphinx and turned it into
a, a King's face. Well,
the way it was told to me was that it is upper and lower Egypt. So, uh,
upper Egypt is actually our new South, right? That's our South. And what,
what the way it's taught to me was that was the mind of Egypt and the
economic section of Egypt was what we see Giza pyramids.
And it's economic.
Because if you look at it as sits between three continents on the Mediterranean
sea, so it's a perfect place to carry your commerce. It's the perfect place.
That's why everybody wants to beat it.
That's why is there war in the middle East? Because it's a perfect place to be.
So do you believe that
some Africans came over here and slave ships or none?
Very minimal. Very minimal, really minimal. So you think it's a myth almost.
Now, does there any scholars that support these opinions?
Are these your opinions or the, where are you getting this from?
So here's the thing.
This is stuff I've studied probably close to 15 years ago.
So I don't remember a lot of my sources or who I learned it from.
But I can give you a couple of names.
What you gotta do is you gotta look up Shaka Atmos.
You got to look up dr Kaaba Kamin, dr Phil Valentine, Bobby Hemet.
Uh, who else is a good Egyptologist? Uh, shock Atmos is real good.
Egyptologist I think you should start dealing with Shaka Atmos, but um,
these are,
these are videos I used to watch and Lexus I used to watch back in a day.
Now I focus on like startups and that's where my brain is.
That's where my knowledge is focused on, right?
But a lot of this stuff comes from my own common sense.
It just does not make sense.
The justically to take people from all the way from over there to bring them
here,
especially when half your stock is going to die when you got people right here,
you have human resources right here. All I gotta do is pop them,
shoot a couple of them. The rest of them are like, all right, fine,
and you enslave them and none of them died except for the ones I actually
killed. Right? I got a whole millions of people right here. Like,
why would I go all the crazy all the way across the ocean that bring people back
across the ocean. It just doesn't make sense. It's a stupid that,
didn't nobody run a business like that. What's up
Jimmy PBS? How many the title was,
how many slaves landed in the U F [inaudible]. Well,
roll it up, scroll it up so I could read that whole thing right there.
Perhaps you like me,
were raised essentially to think of the slave experience per mile in terms of
our black ancestors here in the United States. In other words,
slavery is primarily about us,
right from the Crispus attacks and Phyllis Wheatley,
Benjamin Banneker, and Richard Allen, all the way to Harriet Tubman.
So Jordan truth and Frederick Douglas.
Think of it as an instance we were might think of as African American
exceptionalism and other words that it's the black experience.
It's got to be about black Americans. Well, black Americans will think again,
the most comprehensive analysis of shipping records over the course of slave
trade is the transatlantic slave trade database edited by professors,
David [inaudible] and David Richardson.
While the editors are careful to say that all the figures are estimates,
they believe that the best estimates that we have,
the proverbial gold standard in the field,
the study of the slave trade between 1525 and 1866 the in the entire history of
the slave trade to the new world, to the trans Atlantic slave trade database,
12.5 million Africans were shipped to the new world.
10.7 million survived the dreaded middle passage.
Disembarking in North America, the Caribbean and South America.
How many of those 10.7 million Africans were shipped directly to North America?
Only about 388,000 that's right. A tiny percentage.
So a small percentage of all the Africans that were enslaved were actually
shipped to North America. That's probably closer to truth. Hmm.
Danny come from Africa, bro. That don't make no sense. Nobody.
I run a business like that. Well, they,
they're saying that a lot of people did though.
That's 10.7 million people came on boats.
That's what they're saying. [inaudible] slave trade.
I don't know if that means that they necessarily came here.
They could have been going to Europe. They know that. They were saying,
they were saying that it was in the Caribbean trade does not have to come from
Africa. I can trade with you right here in America.
But was it directly to North America is only the under 400,000 right?
Right. Involved in the shipping and going all over the world.
That could be going anywhere. But from Africa,
that's less than 10% African shipped. Yes.
That's less than 10% less than 10% in North America.
But 10.7 million Africans in slaves and moved.
Yeah. 10.7 survive. Right. Were were shipped,
but it didn't say where they were shipped. It says to the new world,
new world is very vague for sure.
Only 388,000 actually made it to North America from Haiti or Jamaica or South
America. So you think, yeah. Right.
So you think that there was probably already a significant population of
Africans that were C bearing that made it all the way over here? Yes.
Well if you listen to the words of Hancock and the discussion of pre historic,
what we would consider prehistoric use of boats and ships,
it's probably likely look at ancient Egypt. Don't you see pictures of boats?
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. So they would burry them. I mean if you could, there was the,
um, what is the big science, uh, museum in LA that had the,
the Egypt, uh, exhibit really recently. It's fucking incredible.
But they had a depiction of the boats they used. Yeah,
I mean they had boats for sure. They definitely traveled. So,
so how can you tell me that a civilization had boats before Europe was literate,
didn't come to America, didn't set up shop. It's just not common.
I mean, just, I don't need to read a book to understand that,
but definitely makes sense if they made it to South America. I mean,
if the old Macs were, I mean if you look at, you pull up a, an image of a,
the OMAC heads. This is heavily disputed.
John Henry Clark is author. You should study. John Henry Clark has a book.
They come before Columbus. I mean, look at that. I mean, these all make heads.
They all looked like that and I stopped the Mexico. Yeah, so it kind of,
if you have a zing,
there has to be a large population of people in order to create these things.
Right. It has to be,
you know, these have to be advanced,
so if they're here already in South America,
why are you going to go across the sea when you got people right here,
you can just in slave South America's connected to America.
Do you think we didn't come up North and they wouldn't take that whoop. Right.
It's just common sense. Well,
particularly when they're finding all this evidence of people that were here
thousands and thousands of years before they ever thought people were the
evidence in the grand Canyon from Egypt.
What I didn't know about that was that is you heard about that part of it?
Yeah. There might be some gold down there. Oh,
is this Egyptian gold in the grand Canyon? Hey,
imagine if they found a fucking Egyptian tomb.
There's Egyptian stuff that's been found in Ohio. Yeah. Yeah.
Although I was looking some stuff up at grandma's telling me I went home and
looked up the separate Mt stuff and like right up the road from where the
serpent mound is, there's been a couple of artifacts found.
They're like 800 artifacts and call mountain. Pull that up. Yeah.
There's mounds in America which supposed to be like pyramids or whatever.
So there's even an Egypt, Ohio. I don't think it's named after that,
but it's literally like in the same spot. Wow. Yeah. Yeah. This, this,
this, this history of human travel is fucking fascinating.
Circumnavigated this globe before a man, it's, this isn't new stuff.
It's new to Europe. It wasn't new to the African race man. Hey,
we been here. They got the mounds,
the archeological evidence from Egypt in the grand Canyon. It's right there.
I've never heard that before. That is interesting.
Archeological evidence in the grand Canyon. This is not part of his story.
He's got to keep you thinking he's got to keep the black people thinking you
were slaves and you came from Africa on boats.
That's what they got to keep you ticking.
But you really think that there's some sort of grand conspiracy to withhold
information
[inaudible].